[MUSIC PLAYING]
The human volcano,
fire breathing--
it's the most dangerous stunt
in the fire eater's
repertoire.
But how does it work?
Well, it all hinges on the
oxygen in the air.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I'm breathing fire, all
that's happening is I'm
burning a fuel by blowing
it over a flame.
So here's my fuel, and
here is my flame--
not very spectacular.
So what's going on?
Well, in order to burn, a fuel
needs to be mixed with the
oxygen in the air.
And at the moment, this fuel
doesn't have enough oxygen
mixed with it in order
for that to happen.
This fuel's not very volatile.
This fuel, however, is very
volatile, which means it
evaporates constantly.
It's evaporating more quickly,
and it's mixing with the air
all the time.
So let's see what happens.
So you might think that
this fuel would be
ideal for fire breathing.
It burns really, really well.
In fact, it burns
a bit too well.
If I use this for fire
breathing, the flame could
jump back to my mouth, and I'd
be in serious trouble.
So it's actually this
fuel that I use.
But in order for it to burn,
I have to mix it
with the air myself.
And to do that, I spray the
fuel in a fine, fine
mist over the flame.
So what's so special
about oxygen?
Well, in fact, oxygen is really,
really reactive.
It wants to react with
other things
to produce new products.
And, in fact, burning is just
the name we give to the
chemical reaction between
oxygen and a fuel.
Now, the fuel we've got here is
a hydrocarbon, which means
it just contains hydrogen
and carbon.
And when we react this with
oxygen, it produces carbon
dioxide and water.
So we've got the fuel.
We've got the oxygen.
There's one thing missing.
In order to get the reaction
going, we need to provide it
with some energy.
And with fire breathing, that
energy comes from the
flame on the torch.
Now once that reaction's
started, it provides its own
energy and forms a kind
of chain reaction.
Now, the end product of this
is a giant fire ball.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And just because I know how that
happens doesn't make it
any less terrifying
when it does.
[MUSIC PLAYING]